all right well it's a pleasure to be
here to speak with you today over the
web
and tell you about what my lab is
working on
um so we're primarily a microfluidics
lab a microfluidic lab that
builds technology for doing biological
research
essentially we consider ourselves
research tools builders
and today i'm going to tell you about a
major focus in the lab
it's about what a third of my lab does
where we use
droplet-based microfluidics to perform
single cell multi-omics
so droplet-based microfluidics is a
subfield of microfluidics where the
overall concept
is to use microfluidic devices
to form these very small picoliter
volume
droplets of water that are surrounded by
an immiscible oil
phase and the microfluidic devices form
them and they also process them
and functionally the way that we think
of it is that the droplets
are the reaction containers the test
tubes if you will
and the microfluidics are the graduate
students or the robots or the pipettors
they're the
the instrumentation that is performing
the operations on those test tubes to do
the biology they will want to do
so um when when we um
generally the way the research goes is
that we conceive of an idea you know a
new
you know it'd be great to be able to
form some new measurement
and we think about what that measurement
entails and we break it down into a
bunch of different steps
and we then build a microfluidic
instrument in essence that
automates doing those different steps
and it's usually just you know what you
would typically do by hand
you know at the bench but now we we
miniaturize that into a microfluidic
chip and all of those steps are done
with full automation on the chip or as
much automation as we can get
and so shown in this slide are the basic
uh modules we call them of droplet
microfluidics
which are um you know first here at the
top left is a droplet
generator this is the microfluidic
device that generates the test tubes
it also encapsulates samples so if you
have say a suspension of cells and you
want to analyze individual cells
you use that droplet generator to
encapsulate those cells in individual
droplets where they can be further
processed
encapsulation is just usually the first
and most basic thing we need to do in
droplet microfluidics
if you want to do more complex assays on
for example those cells that you've
encapsulated
this will require you to go and often
add reagents to the droplets which we do
by pico injection which is the
movie in the middle there and then
sometimes when we want to add a large
volume
to a given droplet so let's say we
digest the cell
to open up its genome get a genome ready
for for
analysis at that point we essentially
want to do a buffer exchange and add a
new reagent
and we do that by expanding that small
concentrated droplet into a very large
droplet as shown
in that movie to the top right
um there's a bunch of other different
modules in drop of microfluidics
these are kind of the most commonly used
modules that allow you to just
form a huge number of droplets and
encapsulate
lots of cells lots of particles
molecules and so on
and to do multi-step reactions in the
droplets now
the reason that this is so powerful is
that is really the speed
and the very tiny size of these droplets
so
the the natural time scale of droplet
microfluidics is around a kilohertz so
the natural rate at which the droplets
are going to be formed and processed by
the microfluidic devices
is about a thousand droplets per second
they can be substantially higher
up to a hundred times higher than that
and it could be uh substantially lower
about 100 times lower you'll see devices
so it spans a broad range
but um the the real sweet spot where
this technology really shines
is in making a huge number of droplets
very rapidly and because those droplets
are only picoliters that's uh
you know roughly 10 10 to the minus 12
and usually these are between
uh 10 microns to 100 microns so you're
talking about 50
picoliters of volume you can make an
enormous number of droplets from just a
relatively small amount of reagents i
believe about a half mil
of sample can form about a billion 10
micron droplets so
you know if you had a way to usefully
use every one of those droplets you can
imagine
doing an enormous number of assays and
so
where droplet microfluidics has really
gone is into
application areas where you need there's
this need for very high throughput
analysis and so much of the current uh
space is focused in single cell analysis
where you have a large number of cells
that you want to analyze individually
and they're the throughput the ability
to take a suspension of
tens of thousands hundreds of thousands
of cells and isolate them in individual
droplets
and also the very small volume which
keeps the cellular
components whether it's the lysate of a
cell that you've digested or a secreted
molecule
it keeps it concentrated to that cell in
this very small droplet
that is what enables you to get a good
measurement as well you have essentially
a very high sensitivity because
even though you're starting from a very
small amount of material you know let's
say just one cell or literally one
molecule
the actual rel the actual concentration
in that droplet because the droplet is
so small
is in a range where you can actually do
a measurement you can actually do
reactions reliably
um so those components are the basic
components that allow us to make lots of
droplets
in some instances there's also a need to
sort through that huge emulsion that you
form so maybe you're
going to use those three components to
make about 10 million droplets which is
kind of typical for us
now what do you do you have 10 million
droplets in a tube
each droplet has a different cell or
different molecule and how do you get
the
the material or the the information out
of that tube to do the next steps of
your experiment
and that's where the final movie at the
bottom comes in and this is something
called a flow dropometer
we call it a flow dropometer or
fluorescence activated droplet sorter
and what it is is basically the droplet
microfluidic analog to a float
to a fluorescence activated cell sorter
um
we take our droplets that have been
formed you know by our previous
instrument
we pack them together and flow them into
this device
that scans them with a laser and then
sorts them according to
the fluorescence measurement uh that's
picked up by the detector
and it's built basically like a flow
cytometer at least in terms of the
analysis part
you have a multi-color detector with
filters and so on that are capturing the
emitted fluorescent light
and then that's being analyzed in real
time by a computer to determine whether
to sort a droplet
the sorting is based on a different
force from typical facts machine
it's uh uses dielectrophoresis and
that's really enabled
by the fact that we have an emulsion we
have a a conductive droplet
uh in an immiscible non-conductive oil
and that um difference in in the um
the the electrical properties of those
fluids the conductive versus the
non-conductive carrier phase
allows us to take advantage of
dielectrophoresis to apply very large
forces to these very very tiny droplets
and actually do deflections as you can
see
in this movie to sort
um so these are kind of the complete
tool kit of droplet microfluidics and
when you conceive of a new idea
typically you take these components and
you mix and match them together
and to optimize for whatever you're
trying to accomplish and what i'm going
to tell you through the rest of this
talk
is a few specific applications where
we've taken
these modules and we've built specific
instruments to perform
a measurement that we thought was
important
so the first thing i'm going to tell you
about is
single cell dna sequencing and this
really gets the bigger theme of my talk
which is on single cell multi-omics
so um omics you know this is a
term that's used to describe when you
want to perform a a
kind of a broad profiling of a universal
kind of information so the
typical olympics is genomics which we've
all probably heard of before
where you want to characterize the
entire genome of an organism let's say
or
the the collection of genomes coming out
of a microbial ecosystem where you could
have
literally millions of distinct cells in
just a small you know
a teaspoon full of seawater for example
now multi-omics basically describes
doing
multiple kinds of omics simultaneously
and and that's what my
the primary idea of my talk is single
cell dna sequencing would be kind of the
base
omics that we're going to perform and
the reason that you would want to
perform this
in the case of let's say microbes is
that if we look at the microbial world
you know there's a huge diversity of
organisms um
and and even just you know a
relatively boring sample like a piece of
crud on the bottom of your shoe could
have
thousands of different species of
bacteria and yeast and so on all mixed
together
um and uh you know we we are also
ecosystems for
for um microbes as well and you know our
gut is full of microbes that help us
digest food and sometimes can make us
sick we have microbes all over our skin
and understanding this microbial life
this diversity is actually
potentially very important to
understanding how those ecosystems
function in the case of human health
how they impact human health now the big
challenge really comes from the fact
that
the amount of dna encoding an individual
microbe is actually fairly large so uh
you know if you think about it just in
terms of information
you have on the order of roughly 10
million
nucleotides for just a very simple
microbe simple bacterium
and if you imagine having hundreds of
thousands of these in a piece of dust or
you know
a milliliter seawater that's a lot of
individual genomes
that are going to be there you know 100
000 times times
10 million a little bit and that's just
in a tiny
tiny amount of sample
now how and all of those are all those
microbes they're different species
they're totally different organisms
so how can we look at that sample
analyze it and make sense of all of that
diversity that's there
well the the common approach to doing
that is to do what's called meta genomic
sequencing it's kind of a jargony term
that basically says that you make no
attempt to actually sequence the
bacteria singly
and instead you just collect all of
their dna into one pool
and you sequence it as a mixture and
that's typically what's done in
metagenomic sampling
genetic sequencing now you can imagine
the challenges associated with trying to
analyze that kind of data
just a huge number of different cells
being mixed together with different
properties
usually the data that you get out it's
shotgun sequencing which means the
the genomes are fragmented into short
pieces of only maybe 100 or a couple
hundred base pairs in length
and so you have this cloud of tiny reeds
that don't necessarily overlap and are
not physically connected together in any
meaningful way that you can infer easily
so how do you make sense of that and
much of the field is actually focused on
exactly that problem how do i make sense
of this cloud of data to say something
about that ecology
but it's in essence it's a you know at
some point it's a it's a feudal iron
the fragmentation and sequencing of
those genomes discards information that
you simply can never
recover by just trying to piece bits
together in the meta genome
and so that was really the motivation of
this project which is to say
well can we take advantage of the
throughput of droplet microfluidics
to sequence each of the cells in that
sample individually to keep the genomes
intact
um so that we don't have this problem of
mixing together dna from different
species that now makes it impossible for
us to
figure out what is this what are the
genes of this particular species and
whatever its properties
and so the strategy that we took was to
essentially
um miniaturize and automate library
preparation
that's typically done in well plate
formats where you could have 384 wells
in a well plate
we miniaturized that down to droplets
and rather than having you know let's
say 10
microliters of sample in each of our
wells we have 10 picoliters of sample in
each of our droplets
just enough to hold a single cell and
all of the molecular biology to do the
reaction
and what the overall concept here is
that what you want to do
is at the end of the day you need to get
all of the dna
onto one sequencing run because the
sequencing instrument
is a very powerful and high throughput
way to sequence dna it's a very
cost effective way to sequence dna but
it's also
not designed for sequencing single cells
so
we need to somehow get all of that dna
coming from let's say a hundred thousand
different cells into one sequencing run
but still know
which piece which little fragment came
from which
cell in the original sample and that's
where our microfluidics come in
and what we did was we came up with a
way
to label the different dna molecules
coming off
the different fragments coming off of a
single cell genome with the unique
identifier we call a barcode
essentially a small tag that tells you
which droplet that dna came out of
and every read that gets on the
sequencer has a tag on the end of it
that tells you it's droplet of origin
and so we can infer
all of the reads with the same tag it
came from the same droplet and therefore
the same cell
and so that allows us to take a mixture
of reads as shown on the left here
and sort them according to their their
barcode tags
back into single droplets and single
cells once you have single cell genomes
you can then do analysis to figure out
what are the properties of that cell
um so this is the microfluidic
instrument that we built and published
do this the first step is a device that
lyses the cell and amplifies the genome
that uses a droplet generator at that
point you now need to
fragment the genome and that is done by
an enzymatic reaction that
breaks the genome into pieces into short
pieces typically in a couple hundred
base pairs in length
and also attaches uh universal primers
on the ends and those primers allow us
to come in
and in the third step by a pcr reaction
to add the barcodes that are unique to
that droplet
and so we had three modules as you can
see
and the last module the the barcoding
module is where we merge
the tag-mented genome of a single cell
with a barcode droplet that has a single
molecule
a single sequence a barcode sequence
into a large droplet that contains the
enzyme react
enzymes for the doing the reaction and
that's where we get the
fragments to get the barcodes on them
the result of all of that is then a
bunch of droplets where each droplet has
a fragmented
amplified and barcode barcoded genome
from one cell
you could just break that emulsion by a
de-emulsifier
and then collect the the aqueous
fraction which has all the dna
now properly indexed and you can put it
on the sequencer and essentially get the
kind of information that i described
earlier
so uh the net result of that is that
you have in your computer basically you
have now a
list of barcode groups barcode clusters
we call them
and a given barcode cluster has all of
the reads the sequence reads coming from
a single cell or a single dropper
and so it's kind of a profile of that
cell's genome
and um the cool thing about that is that
so so one of the problems actually is
that
you're starting from one genome so
you're never going to get
100 coverage meaning literally you're
never going to read
every single base of a single cell
because there's loss in all of these
steps it's they're not 100 efficient
typically you get on the order of 5 10
of the single cells genome
and what this means is that much of the
genome doesn't actually connect together
you have sort of reads that may be near
each other but there's a gap between
them there's no way to know where they
are with respect to one another
now in the case of typical metagenomics
this is a major problem because if two
reads aren't physically connected
there's no way at all to associate them
there's no way to know that this reed
and this reed
were in the same genome or in totally
different genomes corresponding to
different species
however when we barcode our our genomes
those disconnected reeds now have a tag
telling us they were from the same cell
and so we can associate them together
even if they're not physically connected
and this is very powerful because it
allows us to generate association maps
from the kinds of things that
you simply can't do easily with
metagenomics so for example
the different kinds of phenotypes you
think of with bacteria that you care
about and
you want to um be able to characterize
are things like antibiotic resistance
right something that makes a particular
species able to
resist an antibiotic um virulence factor
something that could take let's say an e
coli that is
that is essentially benign and turned
into a pathogenic color that can make
you very very sick
you know these two things are encoded by
essentially modular components of
genetic sequence that are shared between
microbes and so you could see a
virulence factor
in in one species and the exact same
virulence factor in a totally distinct
species because bacteria tend to
mix dna with one another and so there's
not a way to associate
that virulence factor with a specific
species however we can do that because
we know now that that virulence factor
has that tag
that was associated with all of the rest
of the reeds coming from that cell
so now we can robustly associate it and
we can associate it with other things
that we can measure
like antibiotic resistance and it's
really the combination of these factors
that you want to be able to characterize
when you're looking at
you know am i going to get sick with a
drug resistant
um strain of e coli or or something
right
um in the sample and that's something
you can really only get robustly from
uh single cell dna sequencing another
interesting thing which is a related
kind of
challenge informatic challenge is
characterizing the relationships between
bacteriophages
and bacteria so down at that microbial
world level you have
a war going on between between bacteria
and the viruses that infect them and and
as you might expect i mean it's a zoo of
different kinds of creatures down there
there's a huge number of different
viruses that infect bacteria
and what is is known is that actually
a single bacteria a single virus may
infect multiple different types of
bacteria and
also a single bacterium might be
infected by multiple viruses
and so you can imagine a very
complicated network of interactions
between
the bacteria and the viruses that infect
them and this is a way
because the you know there isn't
necessarily a one-to-one correspondence
between a virus
and and bacteria species this is a way
the single cell analysis is a way not to
associate them robustly because
if we see virus dna or rna within
the the cell body by as measured by this
method
of a given bacterium now we know that
virus was at least present
physically present with the bacterium
and we can start to generate
complex um phagos interaction maps
um so this you know and and i guess just
to summarize all of this the reason that
this is powerful is that
it gives us now this ability to really
untangle the
the the kind of the the hairball um
of of of complication that you typically
see in a metagenomic
sequence analysis because now we can
associate uh
collections of reads with single cells
and because of
where the use of droplet microfluidics
which is so fast we can do this for
hundreds of thousands of single cells in
a single experiment so we're getting
you know an extremely high throughput
map or a very comprehensive map of
what's present in that sample
so you know one of the the issues with
bacteria however is that it's
metagenomics is definitely important
and there's a large number of scientists
who study it but it's not necessarily
the
most um importance to human health and
so
you know we we recognize that we built
that technology
you know that has these three different
components
this is something that an individual lab
is never going to be able to easily
replicate because it requires just far
too much skill
um to to build the chips and to run them
properly so
you know clearly if this is a useful
technology which we definitely believe
it is
you essentially need to commercialize
you need to turn into a
you know an idiot-proof box that can run
every time and so we thought about
commercializing
and i created a company called mission
bio which now sells this instrument
but they're not focused on microbes
anymore they're they're focused on um
on cancer because cancer is another
example where um
heterogeneity of genomic sequence is
relevant to
the phenomenon that you're into them
which is how does cancer develop
grow resist therapy and so on um
the the other nice thing about uh
commercialization is that
you get professional engineers rather
than graduate students building things
up the graduates
they did a great job but they're not
professional engineers with you know
decades of experience
and so at mission bio they were able to
really take that complex workflow
and reduce the complexity down
significantly into just two steps
that run in a fully automated fashion on
a single chip
um it has essentially the same steps as
before
we have an encapsulation and a digestion
this digestion uses a protease that's
optimized for digesting human cells
um and then there's a barcoding step
where that digested lysate
gets simultaneously amplified and
barcoded
and you get out the similar kind of
tagged sequence data
so why did they switch to cancer and why
is that important well
cancer is a complex disease where the
changes in the genome essentially
dictate how the disease is going to
progress over time
and uh it's a it's a it's a randomized
process
that is under a kind of selection very
much like a darwinian evolution
you know the cancer cells are mutating
and being selected for
their ability to grow within the body
and so
how that process happens first of all is
not defined necessarily well defined
right it can it can literally be
different for every single person that
has
a given cancer and so you can imagine a
complex
array of outcomes especially at the
genetic level
for different people with that disease
which is sort of highlighted here where
you could have
you know a single cancer cell branching
off into multiple different genetic
lineages
now the reason that this is important to
map is that
your goal when you're when you're
treating cancer is to kill
all of the cancer cells because if you
don't kill them all and you leave
you know a cell that can grow without
end behind eventually that can kill the
patient
and this is a known problem of course in
cancer it's one of the reasons it's
essentially
incurable disease in most scenarios is
that um cancer does evolve in what
you know just in many ways like
according to darwinian evolution where
initially the you'll have the initial um
diagnosis of cancer you'll apply a
treatment you'll have a remission where
you kill many of the cancer cells but
not all
and then over time those cancer cells
grow back and you typically get a
resistant
uh form of the disease that is no longer
responsive to that first treatment so
you now need to apply a second treatment
that's distinct
you knock the cells down you get
remission you buy some years hopefully
but then it's gonna come back um and so
you're you're effectively performing a
selection on top of this heterogeneity
this genomic heterogeneity
and you can imagine that if we had a way
to characterize in detail the genetics
of the disease at this early stage maybe
we could choose our treatments better
to prevent this um this regrowth you
know to kill essentially all of the
cancer cells that are most important
to kill and so that was really the
vision of the company
and uh they built the technology around
doing that and
this is a nice example where you could
start to see the the need for this sort
of a thing so here's a patient that
um early on had uh uh
when we characterized their cancer cells
using the mission biotechnology
saw that the population basically
consisted of
by far a dominant population of these
blue cells which have this combination
of mutations in the genome
and a small population of cells these
green cells
that have this uh other combination id82
sf3b1 um and then actually there's a red
population which we didn't even pick up
at the beginning uh treatment is applied
the
blue population narrows the green
population sort of stays the same
as another treatment is applied the blue
population narrows even more
but the green population is starting to
expand and now that red population which
we didn't even detect the beginning
starts to expand as well
and by the time there's a full relapse
what we find is that the blue population
is essentially
nearly gone it's still present but it's
it's massively reduced compared to the
initial fraction
uh but now we have this green population
taking around
nearly half of the cells the cancer
cells and this red population taking
about a quarter
i mean at this point you have a
resistant uh tumor that's no longer
responsive to the
to the treatment um so it would there
have been a way for us to detect
the these red the red cells and the
green cells um
and have chosen a therapy that would
have prevented them from
recurring and that's really the hope the
goal
um so that's the sort of thing that
we're interested in doing with single
cell
multi single cell dna analysis and i
just want to add a little bit before we
get into some more detail of that
on how we're using this for um single
cell multimeter why we want to do single
cell multiomics
so the genome is kind of the most basic
programming of a cell of what a cell is
but that genetic information is
transcribed
into rna and then that rna is translated
into protein
and so information flows from the genome
through the transcriptome to the
proteome
and in many ways you can think of it as
the genome as being the you know it's
the genotype it's the fundamental
programming
and the pro the proteome is the is kind
of what the cell
actually is it's actually the cell body
and provides all of its functionality or
much of its functionality the enzymes
and so on its binding properties with
different its ability to recognize
different molecules and so on
is really in the proteome and so if we
are just focused on the dna
of the cell we will be limited to the
genomics to just the basic programming
but we will not necessarily know how
that programming manifests as the actual
cell
and what is known is that actually the
way information
goes from that basic programming to the
actual phenotypes of the cells is very
complicated and controlled
in fact um you know we all we are
comprised of cells that all have
identical genome essentially
um and yet we have skin cells and liver
cells and heart cells and so on
that have different phenotypes so um you
can't
just be you can't assume that a fixed
genotype will always lead to the same
phenotype there is not a one-to-one
linkage there and so the goal
of doing multi-omics is really to be
able to start to
to tie together genotype and phenotypes
at the single cell level so we can
understand how genotypes drive different
phenotypes under different circumstances
so one of the first ways that we thought
to do this was to
try to start to capture protein
information
into our multi-omics analysis
and our idea was well um you know
just to go back to this slide you know g
sequencers dna sequencers are great
machines we want to use them as much as
we can but they are
dna sequences they are not protein
sequences you analyze dna with them you
don't analyze protein with them
so how could we integrate um protein
information
into the sequence data that we get out
of our dna sequencer
rather than having to do two totally
disparate measurements right a
measurement of the genome and
simultaneously a measurement of the
proteome
with two disparate methods would be very
very challenging to do with the single
cell level
so our goal was really how could we
merge those two measurements
into something we could read out with a
sequencer and our idea
was to use something called an aptomer
which is
a piece of dna or rna that
in many ways is kind of it behaves sort
of like
an antibody but it is itself just a
nucleic acid
so an aptomer is just a piece of dna rna
that folds into a
conformation and that conformation has
the ability to recognize specific
molecules or epitopes actually bind
to cells but it is nothing but a nucleic
acid
so if you were to take those aptamers
that bind to specific cells
and label the cells as shown in this
slide if we take this collection of
aptamers
mix them with the different cells and
allow them to bind
if we choose aftermers that binds
specifically to certain cell types
or certain epitopes then now what we
would end up with
is essentially we've added synthetic dna
to the cell it's the aptomer's bound to
the cell
and so if we we can now take that cell
and we can sequence it using our our the
pre the approaches that i've described
earlier
and we could simultaneously get
information about the genome and the
aptamers that are bound to it
so this is a way to start to integrate
uh protein information
into the into the measurement and the
nice thing is that there's a variety of
aptamers that have already been
described
we basically showed that you could just
pull some aftermers off the shelf
and you could bind cells to them they
bind specifically and we can correlate
that information with
the cell type the known cell type um so
aptamers are nice but one of the issues
with aptomers is that
they're not as uh they're not always as
good
as antibodies for binding they're not as
potent finders there's not as many
available and um there's just certain
things you you can't bind as well with
with accuracy because of the fact that
they're nucleic acids
that you can do with with antibodies and
so we we wanted to figure out well could
we use a similar kind of technique for
antibody based binding
now this is of course there is a long
history of using antibodies to
characterize cells
this is typically done using a flow
cytometer where you'll take an antibody
labeled with fluorescent dyes and you'll
bind it to a
suspension of cells and then those cells
will become fluorescent
based on whether or not they bind that
antibody and if you take
different antibodies labeled with
different colors of dyes and you make a
cocktail
you can now take a mixture of cells
adhere that mixture of antibodies to
them and you'll get cells
becoming fluorescent in different
combinations of colors depending on
which antibodies bind to them
and then of course you deconvolute all
this information with a flow cytometer
now the challenge with that process i
mean it works great and it's been
you know one of the mainstays of
immunology and other cell biology
experiments for for decades now but the
challenge with it is that
um you know there are literally tens of
thousands of distinct antibodies you may
want to use or even more
um to characterize a population of cells
but
there's there's only so many colors of
fluorescence distinctive colors of
fluorescent dye that you can use
simultaneously
and typically what this means is that
it's difficult to do one of these assays
with more than just a handful of
antibiotics five
ten you know if you're a real expert lab
maybe you can do twenty
but that's really where it bottles it it
um
it runs out and the reason is that you
know the visible light spectrum which
you're limited to
for the fluorescence analysis is only so
wide and
you can only fit so many different
channels in there
now uh a solution a very clever solution
to this was to recognize that you don't
necessarily need to use light
fluorescence light as the way to label
antibodies there's other labels you
could use
in particular um you could use rare
earth elements which have very
sharp uh very narrow peaks as read out
on a
mass cytometer and this allows you now
essentially to
have up to tens or or even up to 100
distinct antibodies labeled with
different
what are called mass tags they
essentially take the form of a
fluorescence
uh they play the same role as a
fluorescence probe but it's a it's read
out with a mass cytometer a mass
spectrometer
but even then you run out of channels
the distinctive channels because there's
just so many rare earths
so our idea which we called ab seek was
a was essentially to recognize well we
could swap out
those those mass tags now or those
fluorescent tags we can swap those out
with a dna tag
right so we generate a contract that is
shown on the right which is an antibody
with the dna oligo
attached to it and now you could bind
your cells with that
antibody and when you do that you
effectively pull onto that cell that
synthetic nucleic acid tag
and so this molecule this oligo function
this this um oligoconjugated antibody
is essentially kind of a transducer it
transduces a protein based signal as is
recognized by the
the antibody into a nucleic acid signal
that you can read out with your
um with your dna sequencer
and and the nice thing about this
simpler to similar to the aptamer work
is that now we can just
uh sequence that dna along with the dna
of the cell
getting tagging it just the same way
using the barcodes and we can get all
that information out simultaneously
so we built a microfluidic device to do
that and uh
it uses basically exactly the same
method that you've seen previously
and lo and behold we're able to label
different cells
with different combinations of
antibodies and get nice clusters that
look
for all intents and purposes they look
like what you get from a flow cytometer
using fluorescence
tags but these are our informatic
accounts
sequence counts to label the different
spots here
and what um some very clever labs
recognize is that well
you can actually combine ab seek in
combination with rna-seq as well and
perform multi-omics
these are called sight seek and reap
seek where they recognize that if you
just polyadenylate the
um oligo tag that we're using to label
our our
antibodies those will be captured by the
rna sequence analysis
uh that's typically used because you all
mrna is polyadenylated in eukaryotes
and so if you polyadenylate your
antibody tags those are going to get
captured by the same electron body so
now you can start to do
protein and rna and actually these are
now available through some commercial
companies
um for dna and protein it's a little
more challenging because
um uh in the dna analysis we're not
doing a poly
a capture we are actually sequencing
distinct loci of the genome that have
distinct
primers associated with them so in the
case of a cancer cell you may want to
sequence 40 or 50 different
loci to characterize the heterogeneity
of that cancer across
known genes so now we also need primer
sets to
to get to our antibodies as well and
that is something that we now can do we
call this method
dna and app seeker we give it the
moniker dapseq
and we show that we can get
simultaneously a very nice coverage of
the genome for those
loci and simultaneously antibody profile
information
now uh being able to do
rna and antibodies is nice uh it
definitely adds information to do the
two together but in some sense
it's not as powerful as it would be able
to be able to do
dna and either rna or antibody and the
reason for that is that rna
is kind of an intermediate between dna
and protein
and in many ways it represents the
phenotype of the cell best
you can certainly get genotype
information out but it's only going to
be the genotype of the expressed genome
the genome that actually gets translated
into rna or transcribed into rna
the rest of the genome which is the vast
majority of the genome is not
transcribed and therefore is not going
to be readable
and mutations there and especially copy
number variants and so on these are very
important
to cancer so really ideally what you
you know when you're doing rna and
antibody you're sort of getting
phenotype
and phenotype phenotype one and a
phenotype two which is related
what you would really like is genotype
and a measure of phenotype
and that's really what the dna and
antibody allows you to do is it gives
you the genotype
measured directly from the genome
unambiguously
and the phenotype as inferred from the
antibody based binding
and so what i'm going to tell you about
now is how we've used this to
um perform a fairly detailed analysis
of genotype phenotype relationships in
recurrent aml
aml is a leukemia that is uh
it tends to um attack the young and it's
uh
it's often very deadly and so it's
something that we were very motivated to
see if we could apply this technology to
and mission bio has been very
motivated to this as well so our dab
seek workflow
is has been streamlined quite a bit it
now runs on the mission bio platform we
got it running on the platform
initially the platform didn't do that i
just did dna by itself but we optimized
it to do
um antibodies as well my lab did and
you know the workflows as you'd expect
so we take um
cells from take blood cells from a
patient we
have a a panel of antibodies essentially
a mixture of different antibodies to
different known surface profiles that
are known to be
different epitopes that are known to be
important in this disease each of them
labeled with a different oligo
um we then bind those cells with those
antibodies and we get
as you can see on the left there you
know as a cartoon
cells that have um you know different
cancer cells or normal cells all mixed
together where they have antibodies
binding to them
depending on their surface profile those
cells then get
processed through the two-step
microfluidic workflow that's run by
mission bios machine called tapestry
and they get barcoded and during the
barcoding step we analyze the genome and
we get the surface
profile as well and what you can think
of it is as
is the you know i tend to think of it as
the genotype as being kind of the
independent variable
and the phenotype as being the dependent
variable um
you you um although you can you can mix
them around if you'd like
uh whatever is easy to think about um
but in essence what we want to do is we
want to know
for this genotype what are the sets of
phenotype surface profile phenotypes
that we see
and this will allow us to do uh quite a
complex mapping because
right now in aml and actually in most
blood cancers
you do one or the other either you do a
genotype analysis
by characterizing all the mutations
present in the genome sometimes at the
single cell level
or you do a phenotype analysis where
you'll run flow cytometry or mass
cytometry
to get this combination of surface
profiles to fractionate the different
cancer cell and normal cell populations
in the clusters
based on what the proteins that they're
expressing on their surface are
with this approach we can now do all of
that and have linked
genotype phenotype information at the
single cell level
so just to show how this worked the
first thing we wanted to do is we
we just took some blood cells normal
pbmcs
and we did uh the analysis using
dab seek and uh what we found what you
see here on the left
is uh the umap clustering of that data
from the different antibodies that are
binding and you can see that we have
different clusters associated with the
different kinds of cells present in the
blood
and those different cell clusters as
shown on the right um
express different markers and uh blood
cells have been very well characterized
as surface profiles and those bloods
have been very well characterized so you
can actually use this data to annotate
what those cells are
and say you know this is a cd4 positive
t cell this is a natural killer cell
this is a dendrocell
dendritic cell and so on based on what
combination of surface profiles we get
so we get very nice data from the absi
component of the mission biomachine
to show that this is really now going to
provide linkage information the next
thing we did was we took
a different we took two different cell
or three different cell lines
where each of those cell lines is known
to have both distinctive genotypes and
distinctive surface profiles
and they're known all of those all that
information is known these are cell
lines
and so what we should find is that the
genotypes of a specific cell type will
correspond with its surface profile
and so when we do the analysis indeed
what we find is that we get three
clusters as you can see on the left
um we can classify them by surface
profile
using antibodies and we classify them
into those three different clusters jerk
hats case k562 and rajya cells
and now we can go one level deeper and
look at the genotypes and when we map
the genotypes on top
we find that indeed the cells have the
correct genotypes corresponding to the
to the known phenotypes
so this is essentially just showing that
the technology works
we are able to measure simultaneously
the genotypes and the phenotypes
of cells so now we turn to an actual um
case of aml in a in a patient and
uh shown on top is the history of that
patient so so all the patients i'll tell
you about today
all these people have undergone
extension they've had they have
histories that predate when we get their
samples
um so this patient we that we got the
sample at their second relapse
where they were known to have these two
mutations the dn
dnm t3a and the mpm1 mutations that was
the primary
cancer cell population if therapy was
applied
you could see that you were successful
in reducing that
red population down uh over time they
they started to have outgrowth of the
cancer cells again the mutant cells
and they applied another therapy and
essentially they're in a deep regress
remission at that point now when we
actually look
at the the genotypes and phenotypes here
it's quite interesting so shown on the
bottom left there is the antibody based
clustering data and what we find is that
there are a variety of different
clusters they're normal clusters shown
on the right the monocytes dendritic
cells t cells and so on
and then there's this broad sloppy
cluster of myeloid blast these are the
cancer cells
they have a distinctive surface profile
that actually clusters them away from
the normal cells
and now and you can see it's color coded
according to the relapse so
uh or the the progression so at relapse
2
many of the cells were present in that
myeloid
compartment uh at therapy
salvage therapy you see um most of the
cells are
present in the normal population so
you've killed most of the cancer cells
and then it comes back you get that
green progression coming back you know
the cancer cell population and so on
and when we actually map the genetic
mutations on what we find
is that on the right there um the the
cells with the malignant
uh genomes tend to also have the surface
profiles that
that look like cancer cells like myeloid
blasts whereas the normal cells
cluster to normal cell populations and
have wild type genotypes
so this is a scenario where there is a
very tight association between the
genotype of the cell and the phenotype
of the cell
kind of as an elementary understanding
of cancer right where
you know genotype drives phenotype and
so you expect naively a one-to-one
correspondence
but it turns out not to always be true
so this is a different patient where
we found that multiple distinctive
genotypes
actually converged onto a single cluster
of immuno phenotype
okay so now we have different genomes
that are all behaving
similarly cancer-like for lack of a
better phrase
and so what you can see here is that
early on
you have a large population of wild type
and
this malignant population of red and
orange cells with the k-ras mutations
therapy is applied the the cancer cells
are killed for the most part but then
the red population which is a flip 3
mutation comes back
and when we look at how when we map the
genotypes onto the different amino
phenotype clusters what we find is that
we have our normal cell populations are
shown as the blue populations
and you have this mixture of orange and
red cells
which are distinct genotypes sharing one
broad
spectrum of immunophenotypes so this is
a scenario where
you know targeting a mutation which
mutation do you target
it's not necessarily clear because you
have actually multiple different
mutations
that are all giving rise to a similar
kind of cancer phenotype
the the last patient is actually the
inverse of that so this is a scenario
where we take a single genotype and by
applying a treatment we actually
get those cells to differentiate into
multiple phenotypes
so here we have a an orange again our
wild type is blue we have their our
orange and our our
red mutants we apply therapy
we see that we we kill many of the
cancer cells
and then as relapse occurs the flip 3idt
mutant
takes over and if we actually look
at the uh at the antibody
clusters at the at the middle there you
can see that um
we have these multiple different uh
phenotypes that are all being
um that are all coming out of that uh a
single cluster initially
uh and so you can actually map the
genotype information on top of that and
see that
the you know essentially genotypes are
showing up in all
cancer genotypes are showing up in all
the different phenotypic clusters
and so this is a scenario where you know
if you're
many of the modern therapies target
anabolic use antibodies to target
certain surface profiles
of cells and if you were to do that here
it wouldn't necessarily work very well
because
the cancer cells have actually
diversified into a variety of different
surface profiles so you might kill one
of those profiles but there are other
cancer cells
in other compartments that you're not
targeting so this really shows
i guess the totality of these three
patients really shows that it's a you
know as we know
cancer is a complex disease sometimes
you have a very tight relationship
between genotype phenotype
sometimes you have a very complicated
relationship between genotype and
phenotype
and you really need to be able to map
that in detail to be able to make the
best
treatment choices
so in the last bit here what i want to
tell you about is how we are now
expanding beyond dna analysis or nucleic
acid analysis
using sequencing to try to start adding
functional assays
so you know so far we've really really
been constrained by the fact that we
need to take all of that
material coming out of a cell and get it
onto a sequencer
and sequencers are great at sequencing
but they don't do
you know that's all they do so what if
we want to do a functional assay like an
assay based on
its ability a cell's ability to invade
or express a certain kind of enzyme
or that can cause a specific kind of
reaction or so on
um and for that what we need is a way
where we could take those cells and
perform those assays on them before we
go into the sequencing which is
destructive
and so we developed a variant of the
technology now where
before we go into our sequencing we can
print the droplets onto a substrate
and perform perform a functional assay
and the printer uses this essentially it
uses our sorter
to take droplets out of our system and
print them onto a substrate
straight as is shown here um
and it does it in an organized fashion
so every droplet on the substrate has a
known cell in it that you've measured
and you record the position of that cell
on the substrate
you could also add additional cells to
the substrates
and you can add additional reagents
because it's a deterministic droplet
printer you can hover over a spot
and add multiple cells multiple beads
and cells multiple
regions and this is very powerful for
doing a functional assay
and another nice thing about it is that
it's an open system so
after we print ourselves down we have an
open system that we can image
we can put into a culture hood we can do
mass spec on
um and this all provides a lot of
flexibility there and we actually showed
that these printed droplet arrays we can
go with a mass spec and scan them and
get mass spec data out
and this is actually data showing that
where we have an array of droplets that
we've printed down
and on the right is the mass spectrum
coming out of those droplets for a
certain
um a certain part of the spectrum where
we're looking for a metabolite to be
present
so um basically the idea is rather than
just
taking a bunch of cells and collecting
them in a disordered way into a tube of
droplets
we use this printer to print them down
neatly onto a known array
where we can do functional
characterization but at the end of the
day we will want to go into a sequencer
to be able to correlate that functional
information with all the sequencing
information that you've seen that we can
get
so how do we do that and our idea is
basically to
index the droplets with coordinate we
call them coordinate oligos
where we into each of those spots we
print a combination
of of oligos which connotes a
a y component and an x component it
tells you
where on that array you are located a
given droplet is located
and these oligos get captured during the
sequence analysis
and essentially end up as reads to get
in that cell cluster in that barcode
cluster so
for a given barcode group when we sort
all of the reads according to one
barcode group we're going to see
a bunch of reads for the genome a bunch
of reads for the proteome
if you're doing rna analysis you'll have
rna and you'll now also have
a bunch of reads corresponding to these
x and y components
and so now if you've done imaging or
mass spec on this array
you know the coordinate by the location
from your image
and now you also can associate that
location with a given barcode group
based on these coordinate holograms
and we've shown now that you can
actually do this kind of analysis to get
rna-seq data
where you can actually get this kind of
tethered optical and rna sequencing
based analysis
simultaneously there's still some loss
in the process because
transferring the material from the
substrate
into the sequencing workflow we lose
some of the material some of the beads
some of the cells
and so our grid is is uh splotchy in
parts but
we're still getting roughly 50 to 60
percent of the the spots show up in our
sequence data which is pretty good and
we think that can be improved
uh and so i think there's a lot of
opportunity for what we can do with this
technology
we've effectively been able now to
decouple what happens
you know upstream from the sequencing
and then the actual downstream component
so
downstream we we definitely expect to be
able to get dna rna and protein out of
the single cell
at the single cell level uh and now what
we do upstream we think the sky is the
limit you know we can we can print cells
we can image them we can do chemical
assays we can do mass spec we can do
atomic force microscopy
and because everything is a nice
organized grid we can correlate all of
that information together
and we can link it to what by using
these coordinate oligos we can link it
to our sequence data
and so i think there's quite a bit of
multi-omic and
other kinds of characterization we can
do using this technology
and it'll be scalable to the you know
you know hundreds of thousands of single
cells
as current technologies for sequencing
are currently capable of doing
so with that i will uh thank the lab who
has done all of the work
and i will thank you for your attention
and i'll be happy to take any questions
that you have thank you